Eggs were unhealthy and then healthy.
Alcohol is healthy but also dangerous!
Butter was bad, now it's GREAT!
WHAT THE HELL SCIENCE!!
Guys, science isn't perfect.
It's not!
I'm not.
We're not.
And sometimes it's really confusing.
Some studies show fat is good for you, and
more studies show fat is bad you.
Last week, the British Medical Journal released
a study claiming the effects of alcohol were
vastly overstated; and that globally, more
than three million deaths are attributed to
alcohol consumption.
Yet, in the same damn week, Oregon State University
says drinking wine could help you burn fat!!!
WHAT THE HELL.
Okay, science isn't law, we in science accept
more than one idea at the same time, and we
question constantly.
That's hard to do!
It's called cognitive dissonance, or the idea
that two opposed ideas can both be held and
understood in the same head and.
IT'S HARD.
There's a reason we end a lot of our stories
with the words, "More research is needed,"
because a single study is almost NEVER enough
to ascertain actual science.
What the media covers on the other hand…
that is completely different.
One notable example of this is butter and
cholesterol.
As a kid, I remember being taught that cholesterol
is bad.
It's all bad.
In the 60s, the American Heart Association
warned cholesterol could be bad for the heart.
Then, a 1977 study by the Senate Select Committee
on Nutrition and Human Needs resulted in the
creation of the "Dietary Goals for the United
States," and cholesterol was branded as a
baddie.
From there, the government, various associations,
and media spread the word: cholesterol was
bad, vitamins were good!
The fourth estate loves sensation and conflict,
so people started to avoid butter, eggs, steaks,
bacon and other foods high in cholesterol.
The thing is, the science wasn't settled,
it was just popular There's more nuance to
this story, and the scientific community protested
the decision.
The American Egg Board made a campaign so
people would keep eating eggs, and over the
next 50 years, the science slowly pushed people
back from the edge.
Researchers told people again and again over
the years that fat doesn't cause health problems
on its own.
High Density Lipoproteins were discovered
in the late 1920s, and Low Density Lipoproteins
in the late 70s, but cholesterol itself is
created in your liver and helps cells form
protective membranes.
PLUS, it's a building block for vitamin D!
As dietary science progressed, it's been shown
that a low-carbohydrate diet is better than
a low-fat diet, but the public's mindset had
been set.
Nevermind that an epidemic of heart disease
which, in part, prompted this scramble for
answers, was hitting the country, or that
the lead researcher only studied populations
in the U.S., Japan, and Europe who were selected
because they would confirm the results the
researcher wanted.
The thing is, if you lived through this period,
you'd assume science kept flip-flopping!
But that's not the case, instead, the peer-reviewed
science was consistent and the media and public
were simply sending mixed messages to each
other.
Now, new science has finally resulted in the
cholesterol guidelines being removed from
the 2015 government guidelines.
It took a while, because science takes a while!
Longitudinal nutrition studies can take decades
to complete, and have to be giant populations
who are heavily scrutinized!
This is opposed to cross-sectional studies,
which are a snapshot of a sample, still helpful,
but very different.
It takes time to do good science, but we gotta
do it.
With this in mind, I would like to say, we
at DNews report what is happening in science
as best as we can, but let's be honest, we
might make a video next year which says the
exact opposite thing of a video this year!
Hopefully, we spot that and point out the
change, because science isn't set, more research
is always needed.